What should move forward in time with me
and what should be let go as if it's
dead wood and the more dead wood that
you let go of and burn off when you have
the opportunity.
The last it accretes around you here.
Here's something interesting about
forest fires.
You know people have been trying to
prevent forest fires for a long time,
especially that am bear smokey,
right?
He's trying to prevent forest fires and
so because forest fires burn up the
forest and that can't be good,
but here's what happens if you don't let
forest fires burned,
is that while forests collect a lot of
dry branches,
right?
Because tree branches die and would
falls on the forest floor and collects
and so the amount of flammable material
keeps increasing with time and that's
not so bad if it's wet,
but if the amount of flammable material
is increasing and it gets really dry and
then it burns,
then you have a real problem.
The forest fire can burn so hot that it
burns route,
topsoil right off,
in which case you don't have a forest at
all anymore.
You just have a desert and low.
Lots of trees are evolved to withstand
forest fires,
have a certain intensity and some won't
even release their seeds unless there's
been a fire and so a little bit of fire
at the right time can stop everything
from burning to the ground,
and that's also a really useful insight,
a metaphorical insight into the nature
of sacrifice,
right?
It's also a lot easier to let go of
something when you're deciding to let go
of it because you've decided yourself
that you're done with that.
It's a weak part of you.
It needs to disappear.
You do that yourself.
It's much better and much easier than it
is if it's taken away from you forcibly,
in which case you're very much likely to
fight it.
These other.
There's another interesting thing here,
a motif that runs through the entire
Bible.
It's a very,
very powerful motif and it's partly
associated with this idea of walking
with or walking before God and in the
New Testament,
Christ says something like,
my father's will be done and he means
that that will should be done through
him,
and so I can't.
I won't be able to state this exactly
right,
but it's something like this,
you know,
a lot of what people regard as their own
personalities and and are proud of about
their own personalities,
aren't their own personalities at all.
They're useless idiosyncrasies that
defer them,
differentiate them trivially from other
people,
but they have no value in and of
themselves.
They're more like quirks.
I remember once I was trying to teach a
particularly stubborn student about how
to write and she had written a number of
essays in university and got universally
walloped for them and the reason for
that was she couldn't write really at
all.
She was really,
really bad at writing and so I was
sitting down with her trying to explain
to her what she was doing wrong and she
was being very annoying about it.
Very recalcitrant,
very,
very unwilling to listen.
That was a pearls before swine thing,
you know,
and at one point she said it did.
I can write perfectly well,
this university professors just don't
like my style and I could feel my hands
creep towards her neck.
Yeah,
well maybe that'd be funny if it wasn't
true,
but it was also true,
you know,
and I thought what the Hell is with you?
You can't even write and you think you
have a style and not only do you.
Yeah,
no,
not knowing how to write is not a style.
That's the other point.
Right.
And so,
you know,
she,
she instead of humbling herself,
which was necessary and.
Okay.
Right,
because she was a new university
students,
like of course you don't know how to
write.
When were you going to learn in school?
I think so.
So she had this,
you know,
this,
this style issue in it.
It just,
it just didn't go anywhere at all.
And so now,
let's see,
I lost my train of thought telling you,
telling you all those jokes,
don't we asked in terms of above letting
things burn off.
Yeah.
Well,
so she was proud of her insufficiency
outs.
Arrogance,
right?
That's not humility.
It's self deception and arrogance to be
proud of your insufficiency.
That's a very foolish thing.
And that means to cling to the parts of
you that are dead.
Okay?
Now there's this idea that runs through
the Bible,
I think as a whole that.
Okay,
I'll tell you another little side story
here.
I was reading about socrates today and I
was reading about socrates trial,
you know,
he was tried by the Athenians for
corrupting,
for,
for failing to worship the gods and
corrupting the youth of Athens by like
teaching them stuff and asking them
questions,
you know,
which is great way to corrupt people.
And so he knew the trial was coming and
Athens wasn't a very big place in
Atlanta,
about 25,000
people.
Everybody knew everybody.
Everybody knew who the powerful guys
were in everybody,
including socrates,
knew that the trial was a warning.
Do like get out of town,
right?
So we're going to put you on trial in
six months.
And the potential penalty is death.
God,
that it's like.
So.
So socrates had a chat with his
compatriots and they were contemplating
fair means and foul to set up a defense
for him so that he could or to leave so
that he could not be tried and put to
death.
And he decided that he wasn't going to
do that and he also decided that he
wasn't going to even think about his
defense.
And he said,
why?
This is quite an interesting thing.
He said,
why?
He told one of his friends that he had
this voice in his head,
Damon the spirit,
something like that,
that he always listened to in that.
That was one of the reasons he was
different from other people because he
always listened to this thing.
It didn't tell him what to do,
but it told him what not to do.
It always told them what not to do and
if it told them not to do something,
then he didn't do it.
If he was speaking and the little voice
came up and said no.
Then he shut up and he tried to say
something else and he was very emphatic
about this and he said that when he
tried to plan to evade the trial or even
to mount his own defense,
the voice came up and said,
no,
don't bother with it.
And he thought,
well,
what?
What the hell do you mean by that?
Like there's a trial coming and I'm
going to be put to death,
and while he eventually concluded that
he was an old guy in the next 10 years,
he was in his seventies,
perhaps the next 10 years weren't going
to be that great forum.
He got a chance,
maybe the gods were giving them a chance
just to bow out,
you know,
to put his inferiors in order to say
goodbye to everyone to avoid that last
descent into catastrophe,
which might've been particularly painful
for a philosopher and to and to walk off
the world on his own terms,
something like that.
The point I'm making with that is
socrates attended to this internal voice
that at least told them what not to do
and then he didn't do it.
And of course socrates was a very
remarkable man and we still hear about
them today and we know that he existed
and all of those things.
And so back to the back to the walking
with God idea.
You know,
as you elevate your aim,
you
create a judge at the same time.
Right?
Because the new ideal,
which is an ideal you,
even if it's just an ideal position that
you might occupy,
even if it's still conceptualized in
that concrete way,
that becomes a judge because it's above
you,
right?
And then you're,
you're terrified of it.
Maybe that's why you might be afraid
when you go start a new job,
right?
Because this thing is above you and
you're terrified of it and,
uh,
judges you.
And that's useful because the judge that
you're creating by formulating the ideal
tells you what's useless about yourself
and then you can dispense with it and
you wanted to keep doing that.
And then every time you make a judge
that's more elevated,
then there's more useless you that has
to be dispensed with.
And then if you create an ultimate
judge,
which is what the archetypal imagination
of humankind has done,
say with the figure of Christ,
because if Christ is nothing else,
he is at least the archetypical perfect
man.
And therefore the judge.
You have a judge that says,
get rid of everything about yourself
that isn't perfect.
Of course,
that's also what Abraham.
That's also what God tells Abraham,
right?
He says to be perfect,
to pick on ideal that's high enough and
you can do this.
The thing that's interesting about this,
I think as you can do it more or less on
your own terms,
you have to have some collaboration from
other people,
but you don't have to pick an external
ideal.
You can pick an ideal that fulfills the
role of ideal for you.
You can say,
okay,
well if things could be set up for me
the way I need them to be and if I could
be who I needed to be,
what would that look like?
And you can figure that out for yourself
and then instantly you have a judge.
And I also think that's part of the
reason people don't do it right?
Why don't.
Why don't people look up and move ahead
and answer is,
well,
you know,
you start formulating an ideal.
You formulate a judge.
It's pretty easy to feel intimidated in
the face of your own ideal.
That's what happens to cane versus able,
for example.
Then it's really easy to destroy the
ideal instead of to try to pursue it
because then you get rid of the judge,
but it's way better lower the damn judge
if it's too much like if your current
ambition is crushing you,
you know,
then maybe you're playing the tyrant to
yourself and you should tap down your
ambitions,
not get rid of them by any stretch of
the imagination,
but at least put the more reasonably
within your grasp.
You don't have to leap from point one to
point 50 in one leap,
right?
You can do it incrementally,
but I really liked this idea.
I think it's a profound idea that the
process of recapitulating yourself
continually is also the process of it's
a phoenix like process,
right?
You're shedding all those elements of
you that are no longer worthy of the
pursuits that your that you're valuing,
and then I would say the idea here is
that as you do that,
you shape yourself ever more precisely
into something that can withstand the
tragedy of life and that can act as a,
as a beacon to the world.
That's the right way of thinking about
it,
maybe first to your friends and then to
your family.
It's like it's a hell of a finance
vision and there's no reason that it
can't happen.
You know,
every one of you knows people who are
really bloody useful in a crisis and
people that you admire,
right?
Those are all you can think of.
All those people,
as you admire that you admire us partial
incarnations of the archetypal Messiah.
That's exactly right,
and the more that that manifests itself
at any given person,
then the more generally useful and
admirable that person is in a multitude
of situations and we don't know the
limit to that,
but people can be unbelievably good for
things.
You know?
It's really something to behold.